the official death toll from the
coronavirus in China has risen to six
doctors now say the virus can be
transmitted from person to person that's
troubling and that led to fears it will
spread faster prompting increased
precautions like masks especially for
travelers today Taiwan is reporting its
first infection a woman who had visited
Wuhan China that's the epicenter of this
outbreak and it's where we find Ramey
inocencia Ramey good morning good
morning officials here in Wuhan have
designated 9 hospitals as treatment
centers including this one right behind
me that's on top of 61 fever clinics and
an expert medical team now one piece of
good news is that Chinese scientists
have also said they figured out the DNA
sequence of this virus that opens this
up to potentially new treatments and
possibly a vaccine as hundreds of
millions of Chinese residents migrate
across the country to ring in the Lunar
New Year confirmation the virus can be
spread between humans raises the
possibility it can be transmitted in
more quickly and more broadly that poses
an even greater challenge for China and
nearby nations to contain the outbreak
travelers with masks quarantine stations
and temperature checkpoints are becoming
common sights at airports and train hubs
across Asia this man we spoke to outside
of Wuhan Hospital says it's difficult to
contain the spread of the virus but
believes the government can handle it
very well the number of known infections
has risen sharply since yesterday
topping 300 cases in China alone at
least 15 hospital workers in Wuhan had
been diagnosed with a virus if in fact a
person has infected a health care worker
that's obviously of some concern dr.
Anthony Fauci from the National
Institutes of Health says the
human-to-human transmission could be
isolated incidents but when you get
sustained transmissibility from one
person to another to another to another
then you have a more serious problem
because then that would allow for a much
broader type of an outbreak the World
Health Organization says it will
assemble an emergency committee of
experts they will meet Wednesday to
decide whether
this epidemic constitutes a global
emergency and how best to contain it
Gail we're Amy you know Senseo reporting
from Wuhan China thank you
you